foreign
Robbie and Ryan Gosling bringing full
Barbie fashion and energy hi Barbie
hi Ken it feels like anything that
happens gets a huge reaction uh for
Bobby so it's exciting the stars who
play Barbie and Ken in the upcoming
Barbie movie hit the red carpet in Las
Vegas for cinemacon on Tuesday
[Music]
I'm coming with you
you bring your rollerblades
I literally go nowhere without them no
skates here but Margot did Rock a pink
gingham set with matching pink shoes
just like we saw barbie herself wearing
in the first trailer for The much
anticipated film ask for Ryan he donned
a hot pink jacket with a shirt
underneath that reads from director
Greta Gerwig and Barbie fun so what is
going to shock us the most about this
take on Barbie I think it's the
narrative because it's written by Greta
it is brilliant intelligent I think
there are many prolific things that she
says and to have something with that
storyline in that dialogue set with the
backdrop of the most campy Barbie movie
you have ever seen and speaking of
Bretta the filmmaker opted for a darker
Vibe wearing a black pants suit for
cinemacon Margot and Ryan's co-star
America Ferreira followed suit in a dark
brown pencil skirt and black and yellow
top the contrasts and looks could give
of insight into the premise of the
Barbie movie Something the cast has been
tight-lipped about I can't wait for
people to see the film that's that's all
I can say otherwise Mattel will come in
and box me up I feel like the less I
tell you the better expect the
unexpected whatever you're thinking it's
not it's not that continue to theorize
yeah the actual plot of the film has
many guessing but some extended footage
shown at cinemacon might bring more
clarity people are going to be really
really surprised the new footage has yet
to be released to the public but ET can
confirm that in the club Barbie and Ken
are enjoying their Posh life when all of
a sudden Barbie's perfect world starts
to fall apart after she questions her
reality an upset Barbie seeks out weird
Barbie played by Kate McKinnon who tells
her you can go back to your regular life
or you can know the truth about the
Universe I feel like every little piece
of news that comes out to tease people
everyone just gets progressively more
confused and curious as to what this
movie is the extended footage continues
with Barbie embarking on a journey to
the real world which sets Will Ferrell's
Mattel Choice CEO character into a panic
another moment shown Barbie and Ken's
now iconic rollerblading Adventure in
Venice Beach which fans got a sneak peek
at during filming turns out their fun in
the sun goes south quickly after Barbie
gets arrested for punching a man who
slaps her behind I think I would never
correct Barbie and to sum it up the
tagline for the film that struts into
theaters July 21st is if you love Barbie
if you hate Barbie this movie is for you
I mean it's just flips the whole genre
on its head
foreign
[Music]